soyons pas trop ça beau bonsoir des
enfants n'ayez pas peur
notre nounours pêche à la ligne et il
s'imagine qu'il va attraper quelque
chose attendue
vous allez voir patron
là
tu dois te lourd au genre baisse à la
[Musique]
mecques espères-tu attrapé dans le ciel
nounours des étoiles ou des cheminées
voulons pas trop de poissons vau-l'eau
tu ferais mieux de descendre voir
nicolas et pimprenelle non pas avant
d'avoir attrapé un beau poisson volant
bon allô allô pimprenelle nicolas c'est
le marchand de sable
nous sommes au dessus de votre maison
mais nounours pêche à la ligne
il viendra plus tard vous avez raison
allez-y qu'est ce qu'ils disent pas trop
rien ne nous rien pas trop j'ai une
touche sa mort ou le nord c'est sûrement
une pièce de choix
dutoit tu es une ourse regardez
là c'est un chapeau ou un poisson volant
un chapeau là le nours personnage du
courage noir silence patron olala
qu'elle touche là je faire ce que c'est
vous les bourses one de sardines
c'est incroyable qu'on peut pêcher dans
le ciel est neutre et spa à battre
l'ours courage nounours silence patron
on soit en france ou la victoire la
caisse
elle est tellement grosse que je
n'arrive pas la compter patron vous
voulez bien maintenir solidement la
canne à pêche
[Musique]
merci je m'en vais explorer mon
l'échelle de plongée aux pauvres
nounours
il va être bien attrapés et cette fois
il va être encore sa copie au les cocos
le cocan 7e eux qui me faut jadhav là
haut ils ont accroché une vieille
chaussure un mois ne sont alors plus
petits garnements trois là
mais chez nous c'est très drôle petit
diable ballon d'or vite
et toi aussi pas preneur oui
de plus juré au bord d'une rivière et
vous bouffe dodo là je tends ma lumière
donne une énergie aux produits qu'on
dormait vite les enfants n'oubliez pas
de bien faire votre toilette de vous
laver les dents une fête de bord air